that's sort of my domain of concern and
so i'm wondering how it appears to you
well i've been doing a lot of thinking
about it
and i offer these as thoughts only i
think it's
and there's so many of them jordan i
hardly know where to stand start but i
think the first thing i'd say is that in
a democracy we do
enter into a contract if you like a
compact in which we say we'll surrender
those rights but hopefully no more than
those rights which are necessary to
secure the rights and freedoms of others
and that may from time to time vary
that's a logical conclusion so if you
think of as a friend of mine pointed out
uh here the other day think of the blitz
during the darkest days of um the second
world war in britain
i think the social contract if you like
was strong enough for people to accept
that you had to
make sure there was no light escaping
from your house at night you had to have
black curtains drawn so there was no
light so the luftwaffe pilots couldn't
see london and you and your neighbours
were safe and it was accepted that the
police would have the right to barge
into your house and say there's a chinka
light showing there cover it up
and you had no right of conscientious
objection almost to that that was an
extreme example so we're talking
proportionality here
it's important to note of course that if
you follow it through to its logical
extent by well before the war
technically ended the british people
said right we've been through this
terrible disaster we want our freedoms
back and they actually voted
winston churchill out of office
they i i see that as a strong
declaration this crisis is over we have
made unaccepted unbelievably punitive
measures
restricted our freedoms
placed ourselves at great risk it's over
we now want to normalize
[Music]
hello everyone i have the pleasure and
privilege of
talking with
one of the most impressive men i've had
the good fortune to meet in my travels
and
and my investigations the honorable john
anderson
the former deputy prime minister of
australia
he's a respected elder statesman a sixth
generation farmer from northwest new
south wales
he studied history at university and led
the national party australia's rural
political party from 1999 to 2005.
as deputy prime minister
he partnered in one of the most
successful governments in australian
history overseeing enormous economic
reform tax modernization and a string of
budget surpluses which are
in my experience virtually unheard of
especially a string of them these
delivered an average annual gdp growth
rate of 3.6 percent restored australia's
aaa credit rating
and saw average household income
increase by almost 70 percent between
1994 and 2008.
mr anderson has worked on numerous
community service projects following his
career in politics
and now hosts a video podcast which has
become the preeminent one of its kind in
australia on retiring from parliament
mr anderson was saluted by figures on
both sides of the political fence then
prime minister john howard said of him i
have not met a person with greater
integrity in public life
and so and that that's i i had the
pleasure of meeting mr anderson in
australia when i was touring there and
that's exactly what struck me and so
i i wanted i i've done a couple of
podcasts with with john and and uh
i thought we could concentrate on
something tonight discussing something
tonight that
that i'm very ignorant about like all of
us perhaps
and
about covid and and the response to the
epidemic
the political response uh
and not only what the response has been
but perhaps
what it should be and what the dangers
of the response are and i when i was
thinking of who i would like to talk to
about this to explore it i couldn't
think of a better person than john
anderson because of his reputation
well-deserved reputation for integrity
his vast political experience and also
because
at least from the outside it looks like
the responses the political responses to
kovid and australia have been quite
extreme
and caused a fair bit of trouble uh
justified though they perhaps may be at
least people make that argument and so i
thought we could dive into that terrible
mess and
see what
we might conclude and bring everyone
along for the ride so thank you very
much for agreeing to do this and uh
away we go
jordan thank you it's terrific to be
with you i i respect you enormously for
the way you make us think for the way
you encourage people who are feeling
discouraged
for your forbearance and the model you
set when you're under attack for not
responding with fire but rather calm
reason and above all just terrific to
see you up and about and again and
active and looking well
well thank you very much i i have been
feeling substantially better thank god
and i'm hoping that will continue and
the problem with returning fire with
fire i suppose is that you
you end up burning and i've had plenty
of enough of that i would say so
um it's best to try to calm things down
if you can possibly manage it and
hopefully i'll have done that at least
to some degree and might continue to do
it so we'll see so what what have
what have you seen happening in
australia in the west and and and
what have you been thinking about this
well it's incredibly messy and hard to
think your way through it all and i
don't
i
the very bottom line i don't want to
sound like i'm smug
sort of has been who knows it all and
could have done it better
these are sobering times and we've got
to ask a lot of questions i think my
starting point though jordan would be to
say
and this is our little mantra with my
own video series you can't get good
public policy without a good debate and
there's a lot of elements to a good
debate you've got to have a decent level
of understanding you've got to ensure
the debate's not truncated you've got to
ensure that everybody's involved you've
got to try and demystify and
de-politicize it i think on all of those
fronts there have been severe failings
internationally
and in australia
australia's response has been quite
unique partly for historical reasons
partly for geographical reasons
partly because of the unnatu unusual
nature of our federation
partly because the australian people are
surprisingly comfortable with a big
state
with a lot of government involvement in
their lives
we are as i understand getting some
quite uh even mocking press
internationally at the moment for the
nature of our lockdowns they have been
very severe at longer and more severe
in victoria and in melbourne our second
largest city i think than anywhere apart
from in brazil
of all things
um
and i am concerned i'm concerned about
the balances that have emerged i'm
concerned about the misinformation about
the lack of ability for the australian
people to think through clearly they
started out trusting governments
and medical authorities that trust has
been badly damaged
there's now an acceptance we can't go on
like this
so i have to say in the end i am
optimistic i think that our institutions
will survive this the australian people
will say this is enough we've got to
come back to a pragmatic middle ground
where the governments will give back
everything they should it's a big
question
but i make this point in the context of
the horrendous range of really difficult
challenges that confront us one thing
you must note about australia i think
internationally and has been noted
is that we have clearly chosen the
democracy and freedom
in the face of an attempt by an
authoritarian china to say bow your
knees to our authoritarian regime and
way of life
so there's a cause for real optimism
there that australians understand
freedom even though we don't talk about
it much in this country and so well
let's let's talk about that that example
with regard to china to begin with so
can you flesh that out a little bit what
did you see what threat did you see
china imposing precisely when and and
what did you see the australian people
man managing in response to that
well the um uh
china of course we're one of the few
countries in the world that runs a
massive trade surplus with china they
suck in massive amounts of our product
around a third of our exports go to
china
and
even though we import a lot back from
them we do very very well out of it
and now
we
have
i think perhaps along with the rest of
the world assumed that with
liberalization in trade with rising
living standards
more opportunities for a western style
life liberalism would take over in china
we know that over the last seven or
eight years those hopes have been well
and truly dashed that is becoming a very
authoritarian regime
and
australia called for a full and proper
enquiry into covert so that we could
better understand it and cope with
future pandemic threats more effectively
we certainly lit a little with the chin
i'd have to say on that one
the reaction from china was
very unfriendly indeed and ultimately
they issued a list of 14 major
grievances and say that we have broken
the relationship no one will pick up the
call in china at a senior level in
response to our senior people
canada has experienced a similar
freezing out but it's been very focused
on australia because we're in the region
and because of that call for the covert
inquiry also i think the other thing and
was listed in the 14 grievances
was
our insistence that harway we were the
first country that said that the
telecommunications giant should not be
allowed to uh
implement itself embed itself in our
telecommunications system for security
reasons america followed europe
the rest of the world slowly and i think
that's been a cause of real angst but
the point is that i think the chinese
thought we would bend quite quickly and
australia hasn't
notwithstanding the fact that in common
with um other countries you've seen a
lot of business leaders saying oh don't
go too far this trade is important but
as uh as um
henry kissinger put it a little trade
lost can always be recovered freedom
lost is almost impossible to get back
yeah well that okay so there's a number
of conundrums that sort of emerge out of
that because
you know you're making the case that the
australians have
girded their loins so to speak in the
face of an external political and
economic threat despite the fact that
there might be relatively serious
economic consequences to that and so
that will to maintain freedom and that
that fear of
external
what not fear precisely but wariness of
external authoritarianism we still see
that as alive as what and well but we've
seen throughout the west and maybe it's
exacerbated in the case of australia
the willingness to
dispense with civil liberties on the
domestic front in the face of the
pandemic threat and i wonder first about
the legality of of such moves it it
seems to me that if the lockdowns and
the mandatory vaccination policies are
in fact constitutionally valid in
countries like australia and canada and
perhaps the us and
of course europe
that our civil liberties aren't very
well protected at all
and then i also wonder what would happen
to us what will happen to us
broadly speaking when the next influenza
pandemic sweeps through like now that
we've established lockdowns as
acceptable
what level of threat
justifies their imposition
how serious does it have to be like and
and these are
so then i worry about the lockdowns and
certainly about the ethics of the
mandatory vaccination campaign now i'm
vaccinated twice
and my wife is as well although i have
family members who have refused it and
so the division that you see politically
and philosophically runs through my
family and i'm not claiming any moral
superiority in the fact that i got
vaccinated there are a variety of
reasons for it and i won't go into them
but
i'm sympathetic to those who
are leery of the mandatory vaccination
as policy or the vaccinations per se
for because they have health objections
or ethical objections and so
well
those are that's sort of my domain of
concern and so i'm wondering how it
appears to you
well i've been doing a lot of thinking
about it
and i offer these as thoughts only
i think it's
and there's so many of them jordan i
hardly know where to stand start but i
think the first thing i'd say is that in
a democracy we do
enter into a contract if you like a
compact in which we say we'll surrender
those rights but hopefully no more than
those rights which are necessary to
secure the rights and freedoms of others
and that may from time to time vary
that's a logical conclusion so if you
think of as a friend of mine pointed out
uh here the other day think of the blitz
during the darkest days of um the second
world war in britain
i think the social contract if you like
was strong enough for people to accept
that you had to
make sure there was no light escaping
from your house at night you had to have
black curtains drawn so there was no
light so the luftwaffe pilots couldn't
see london and you and your neighbours
were safe and it was accepted that the
police would have the right to barge
into your house and say there's a chinka
light showing there cover it up
and you had no right of conscientious
objection almost to that that was an
extreme example so we're talking
proportionality here
it's important to note of course that if
you follow through to its logical extent
by well before the war technically ended
the british people said right we've been
through this terrible disaster we want
our freedoms back and they actually
voted
winston churchill out of office
they i i see that as a strong
declaration this crisis is over we have
made unaccepted unbelievably punitive
measures
restricted our freedoms
placed ourselves at great risk it's over
we now want to normalize
then you come right back to the
situation that we're now fronting
well the legal implications are massive
in this country
i might i've just literally learnt from
my news service here in australia that
president biden has decided that all
companies in america who employ more
than a hundred people must ensure that
all their workforce is vaccinated that's
80 million americans compulsory
sorry
you said that that's the company's
responsibility to ensure that so does
that mean that the decision about what
health care is appropriate has now been
ceded by the us government to corporate
interests and where the hell is that
going to end precisely i mean covid is a
nasty illness but it's not
it's not as bad as it could be by any
stretch of the imagination and it's some
multiple worse than a bad flu epidemic
but it's in the same general ballpark
and so
these precedents are being established
at an unprecedented rate and there's a
principle underneath it which is well
you can't be too safe
and the the answer to that is the
rejoinder to that is uh
that may be true but don't be so sure
that
the policies that are put in
hypothetically to ensure your safety are
going to have that effect and know
others
and so
and i know there's a professor in canada
who's and i'm i'm i only know the edges
of this story she's a professor of
ethics and she has been questioning the
mandatory vaccination policy on
on nuremberg grounds essentially that
it's a violation of that that enforced
medical treatment the idea that medical
treatment can be enforced by the state
in one of our provinces there were no
exceptions no religious exceptions no
exceptions for health reasons no
exceptions period it's like okay
but
where does that end like what is it
what i do all sorts of things that are
hypothetically dangerous to other people
like drive for example
which i suspect is far more dangerous
than kovid and yet i'm allowed to do
that
you know we're setting a very strange
precedent here and that's a that's a
hell of a law that's just been passed
so
yeah well
you and i are not americans so we look
at america and think of it as a very
litigatious country i would imagine the
president has just opened up endless
disputes
endless at every level from you know um
social media
meltdown right through to
challenges right through to the supreme
court
and you raise the issue of what is legal
and what is not now that varies a bit
from country to country i would imagine
in this country
one of the keys to understanding
australia's response has been to note
that when it comes to health the state
governments remember australia's a
federation that's a young one that was
created well after the united states in
very different circumstances we
inherited freedom
rather than have to fight for it so
maybe there was never much focus on the
philosophies of freedom the underpinning
thinking around it
although you know to be fair to
australians they've fought
fiercely to defend their freedoms
they've not had to sort of design them
think through them have those incredible
arguments think of alexander hamilton
and the debates from the founding
fathers about how to avoid mob rule
preserving the individual freedoms get
the balance right extraordinarily deep
thinking it's created a democratic
garden
in the jungle that is the normal nature
of human relations and governments down
through the ages and then indeed today
but the you know we're not tending the
garden very well the
the jungle's re-encroaching because we
haven't focused much on what's necessary
to keep the plants healthy put it that
way
so
the states have control here
they've approached
this issue differently it's been hard
for the commonwealth government to
maintain a uniform approach and one of
the big legal questions is have the
state-based lockdowns been legal at all
can queensland legally say to me
somebody from new south wales no you
cannot come here
and the balance at the moment uh would
be the courts have said well the
emergency up until now has been such
that they are within their tight
entitled powers and so forth
to do so that would be very interesting
to test again now and it may be in
australia that our commonwealth
government will have to test him again
because as we journey through this um
and i mentioned i'm very aware of the
interesting international press that
australia is getting at the moment but
the polls are showing now the australian
people are saying look we now get it
we went for de facto elimination
originally the idea was flatten the
curve so our health system can cope
it morphed into a de facto we're so far
from anywhere we're so privileged we're
so fortunate we can go for elimination i
never thought that was realistic
but the polls are now clearly showing
that whilst the australian people are
taking a probably not unreasonable sort
of insurance policy
related to the vaccination as we get the
vaccinations up we think things should
be opened up again
uh and we'll have to live with this and
at that point i think there will be in
this country tremendous resistance and
reluctance to lock down again
because they've been so severe
particularly in victoria that people
have said no the costs are
so high
and part of the problem we've had is a
sensationalization of it all by the
media i'm sorry to say that but
remarkably little really balanced
commentary it's been politically driven
from the right and particularly from the
left
and the left and those in secure jobs
particularly with a publicly funded
broadcaster their jobs go on
even in a lockdown situation they feel
safe
for their own families now i'm an
essential worker not as a farmer
i can't go into complete lockdown
socially i'm in lockdown just about to
come out of it now out in rural
australia but in terms of my occupation
and like
hospitals and nurses and doctors they've
got to keep going there's a bit of
hypocrisy on this oh no we want to be
safe in our secure jobs
in whatever
bureaucratic
enclave or media enclave you work in but
those people who look after me and feed
me and all the rest of it no no they've
got to keep going
pulling all of this together
i think
it will be very difficult after this
frankly for australian governments to
introduce lockdowns again without very
sound reasons so there's a building
awareness we're going to have to live
with this
and i think there's a building
it's quite strong you can feel it and
it's reflected in the polls
and it will be a payout on governments i
think state governments as well as the
commonwealth uh if if they ignore
the feeling that this has gone too far
in the future so we've got two state
governments that are holding out they're
still effectively saying we can
eliminate this
which i think is nuts
and i think their people will ultimately
realize that as well so a bundle of
issues in there but a rising awareness
that there's been a lot of emotion and a
lack of balance
and now emerges that the mental health
crisis amongst young people in victoria
is really serious and has not been given
proper waiting in the debate
nor is the economic impact and the fact
that we are using our children's money
to prop businesses up no country has
blown out its public debt in percentage
terms as quickly i don't think as
australia has why mind you had a very
low debt basis because of certain past
governments
to begin with and even after this our
debt to gdp ratios
will be relatively manageable by
international standards but the trend
lines are not good and we are borrowing
from our children this is our children's
money
right well yes so
we need to talk very seriously all of us
about the cost of the safety
because
the cost isn't safe right so we're we're
taking one risk to prevent another and
so it's always a matter of balance of
risk there isn't a there isn't a pathway
to safety through all of this and so i'm
also concerned like
to make the vaccines mandatory is going
to do and to punish people who refuse
them for whatever reason they refuse
them
is
it seems to me that it's a sign of the
failure
of
the vaccination arguments essentially
that if you if if you haven't made the
arguments credible enough to convince
the percentage of people that you think
should be vaccinated to be vaccinated
then that's a failure of your argument
and then to move to use political force
and
police force for that matter obviously
to insist
is only going to increase the distrust
that's driving the resistance to the
vaccines to begin with you know you
spoke at the beginning
of people's decrease in trust in the
medical establishment so to speak and
also in the political establishment
when when they have to when
when those systems resort to force to
impose
their view of what the proper pathway is
to safety
that's going to produce a long-term
permanent serious damage in the
credibility of those institutions and
that's going to have a tremendous cost
in terms of health as well
so
i don't understa so and then i've been
trying to think through a solution so in
canada we have a fairly high percentage
of people that have been dually
vaccinated and it seems to me that the
appropriate approach is something like
for the governments to say very
honestly and carefully to people
we've made the vaccines as available as
possible to all of you
there's nothing standing in your way but
your own choice that's preventing you
from being vaccinated as a consequence
we're going to reopen our country
radically on this date
and then your destiny is in your hands
as it should be
and it seems to me that hoping that the
vaccination rates are going to exceed
90 percent i think that's a high-end
estimate and i might be wrong about that
is a pipe dream there
too much force is going to have to be
applied to people to get them to do that
and many people will just not do it
and then what are we going to do with
those people are they now pariahs are
they now criminals and and if they are
because it's going to be a big chunk of
the population how exactly are we going
to deal with that so i see that we're in
danger of
exchanging the possibility of
pandemic damage with the certainty of
the danger of authoritarian imposition
so
well so that's
i'd like you to to respond to that i
guess and tell me what you so i that's
that's what i think the policy should be
is that
we have the vaccines that they may not
be as accessible in australia yet as
they are in canada we have plenty of
vaccines in canada it's like
i think the government and the health
authorities would be much more credible
if they said look we really think these
vaccines work but we're not
we're not in the business of forcing
them on you
you can make that choice we've done what
we could to provide them for you and now
it's in your hands
and is there is that a stupid idea like
because i don't know but i i'm not
impressed by
this creeping authoritarianism in the
name of public safety i just can't see
that that's going to go well i i think
it's going to cause more damage than
it's going to do good
you know i think
it comes back to this initial
proposition i think that the quality of
the debate is critical to getting good
outcomes and the quality of the debate
in many ways has been very badly
interrupted
so
we had an unbelievable situation in
australia where we had some quite senior
people saying astrazeneca
was dangerous because of blood clots in
fact you know you're infinitely less
likely to get a blood clot from
astrazeneca than a girl on the pill
so we're going to say well girls should
on the pills should come off the pill
all right because there's a danger of
blood clots we're not going to say that
but we had some quite senior people
driving that
and
yet in britain of course um the people
the lady loves coach
co
inventor and developer of the product uh
a lovely lady whose name is scotia at
the moment went to wimbledon and they
gave her a standing ovation
and people were saying well she came to
australia would probably send it to our
equivalent of siberia the different
responses are extraordinary who's right
now we have one of our leading medical
experts who was one of those casting
doubt on it saying that perhaps it's the
best one of all
so you're getting this confusing advice
how are people meant to find their way
through that
and that feeds into your narrative and i
think in the mind
the quality of public debate becomes
very important
i just wonder what on earth is going to
happen in america now it'll be very
interesting to watch as we speak if i
understand the news correctly
you know that 80 million americans are
going to be told you will have a
vaccination now this is the land of
heaven rich good luck that'll be another
war on drugs like that that's not that's
not implementable as far as i can tell
in the us in particular i mean
the people there who
are
anti-covet vaccination
they're not doing this trivially like
they're committed to it and the
americans can get committed to something
like no one else
and so this isn't going to produce a
minor backlash and it feeds into these
conspiracy narratives that are starting
to undermine our society as well as you
know that the government is
fundamentally untrustworthy and and so
are the health organizations and so
anybody who's vaguely conspiratorial in
their outlook
that's just going to be like
given a massive boost by this sort of
political move that's how it looks to me
and then you go back to the social
contract that i talked about earlier
then in a democracy we agree to
surrender some of our freedoms in the
broader common good
uh and that we then in
proportion or in sort of ways that are
proportional
agree to limit them in emergencies and
we're often willing to do that because
we will
if we're frightened we will flee for
security over freedom will we then
demand that back again but now this
breakdown in trust that is common to all
western countries and it's very
interesting in australia the australian
national university one of our best
universities
uh has been tracking confidence in our
commonwealth governments plural since
i think that's right uh and um it's been
a dismal picture the graph is gradually
drifting away we're less and less
trusting uh of um
of
governments and people in them
although funnily enough australians i
think are still quite
sort of ideologically
friendly towards government they're very
cynical about politicians that's what's
happened there
there's a bit of a disconnect there
but if you look at that
long-term trend he used to get a blip
when there was a change of government a
massive surge in confidence and they
needed to dissipate away until
as a government became unpopular and
made tough decisions or lost its way and
then there'd be a lift you're not
getting those lifts anymore so we went
into this covert situation with
politicians knowing that they're not
widely trusted
uh and that lots of people in the
community would think oh well they're
doing that for his if for political
reasons or looking after their own hide
they're not concerned with us so
they rolled out experts at every point
medical experts now we have wonderful
medical services in this country and i
do not want to sound
unnecessarily critical however of course
they focused very heavily
on saving lives that's their job
and so they gave advice all the time it
was designed to save every life possible
and then it's extraordinary we got to
the end of last year i think we're in a
population 25 million only 810 people
have died of covert
but it meant that the australian people
how they meant to get adequate
information when they're only getting
one side of the debate there's nothing
about the payoffs what will it mean for
mental health
the suicide unit at the university of
sydney
estimated at one stage that the suicide
rate would
increase threefold and that
that increase would be vastly higher
than as i understand it then the number
of people who'd lose their lives to
covert
remarkably little attention paid to the
realities that the people who were being
badly affected were in certain age
cohorts and often had co uh you know
medical problems co-morbidities um in
fact an average of four amongst the
people who have died as i understand it
and and
that very frequently and i may be wrong
about this um
i'm about as perhaps as ignorant as the
average person in this domain and that
might be just right for this
conversation in some sense but i also
um with regards to the death statistics
my
is it the case that
no matter what the pre-existing
condition was
if the person was positive for covid and
they died the death is attributed to
kovid
and that's like that makes the basic
statistics upon which all these
decisions are being made well
questionable i'm not saying that it's
wrong but it's certainly questionable
can we trust the death rate statistics
do we actually know how dangerous this
illness is now people look at such
markers as as excess mortality over a
given time period and that seems to me
to be more reliable but it's not
unreasonable to ask these questions and
that's and that's partly your point
about the necessity of debate and that
opens up a broader issue too you know um
about how those sorts of debates should
be conducted and i can't help but think
that
it's going to become incumbent upon our
political leaders to use the kind of
platform that you and i are using right
now
and actually talk to people
yeah that's never really possible right
yeah i think that's i think that's
important because part of what's
happened i want to sound overly critical
of our health
offices and what have you
many of whom i have a high regard for
some of whom i think have bought into
the sensationalism but keeping in mind
that their job is to present the medical
side
but then
a magnificent health service of the sort
that we enjoy in australia people
cynical about it but by international
standards it's pretty pretty darn good
it costs a lot of money
uh what are we going to do if we can't
afford those intensive care beds in the
future that depends on a prosperous
society our children
are going to inherit a vastly larger
debt they will not be as prosperous and
we know from the research so they're
quite
distraught about this quite despondent
they're wondering whether
australians are very aware that our
economy has been blown off course it's
been magnificent and it's held us an
incredible stead and that's why we've
been able to spend a lot of money on
insulating people it's an irony isn't it
governments shut economies down
deliberately and knowingly and then
try to put the system on life support by
pumping money in directly and
australia's been able to do a great deal
of that because of its economic strength
in the past but we're dissipating it
away at a very time when we face other
huge challenges
the demand that we do more on climate
which will cost money
you know the reality that australia will
have to spend more than two percent on
gdp of gdp on defense we're going to
have to um the whole range of other
things that we're going to spend money
on that must be fed into the debate as
well so that people can make informed
decisions and this has been a big part
of the problem politicians have had to
say listen to the experts because they
know they won't be trusted
whereas in reality if the system was
working properly
people would be saying we put the
politicians there to balance these
things and to lead us through it so they
can say here are the real dangers of
covert that we know about and along
comes delta to be fair and that makes it
even harder it's different and it
affects more people when it's more
contagious but
here are the realities on the health
side here are the trade-offs in economic
terms here are the trade-offs in terms
of the education of our children here
are the trade-offs in terms of
depression and anxiety and self-harm
the right way through this is such and
such a road but that's not what's been
fed to the populace it's saved every
life every life lost well of course it's
a tragedy
but then there's another reality and
that is that the delayed diagnosis of
other illnesses is we've tried to keep
our hospitals free and declined the
system and delayed operations on cancer
and so forth over time we'll realize
that there were real trade-offs within
health as well
and my job my point is that we actually
elect politicians to guide us through
this on the best available information
but when trust is broken down in the
compact it's very hard to get that right
and part of what's happened here is that
politicians have had to say we're taking
medical advice sometimes they don't tell
us what that was by the way rather than
we're balancing that with all of these
other factors and i'm putting it before
you the people i lead on behalf of the
government
hard to do that when trust is broken
down and and and we all know how
important that is to relationships in
the end then it's easy to default to
expert advice
but what is happening as a consequence
that what that means in some sense is
that
the medical profession starts to bear
the weight of political decisions
and to the degree that people are
skeptical about political decisions then
they're going to start to become
skeptical about the experts so the
politicians are by relying on experts
they're
avoiding their responsibility they're
they're they're shunting the risk off on
people who have enough on their plates
as far as i'm concerned and then we have
the breakdown of trust in the medical
system which i really believe is going
to be tremendously exacerbated by
mandatory vaccines
i i i i agree with you i agree with you
this is i think one of the if the
greatest threat to our freedoms in the
west is our own self-loathing and the
breakdown of trust and confidence in one
another those sort of cultural issues um
we're now extending it into other areas
you know into science and so forth
science has offered us the way through
but then you have the serious in this
country in my view very serious and
unwarranted undermining of confidence in
astrazeneca it
really worried me at the time and i look
back on it and i think i hope people
have learned some lessons out of that
i've had the first dose i'm waiting for
my second it wasn't very pleasant as it
happened i did get a reaction and so did
my wife um but you know no hesitation
we're lining up for it we go back for
the second one i'm just very very
thankful we actually have these vaccines
how wonderful is that that's a big tick
to science
but then you've had medical officers
saying no no no this is bad and then
they switch
well that's also why we shouldn't be
hitting people over the head with the
necessity of those you should do this
because it's good for you it's like no
no look that you don't understand the
history of vaccinations has been very
positive now we understand that we're
doing this in a bit of a rush and that
you might be leery about that but it's
our considered opinion that this is
actually of great benefit to you
and we're not going to twist your arm
we're not going to force you we're not
going to put in draconian measures to to
insist that you do this
but i believe that that would be much
more compelling narrative and that many
many more people would for certainly
fewer people would object to the
vaccines that way and i think more
people would take them this this force
and that the force as well this this
next issue
you know the idea that it violates the
nuremberg conventions that's a very
interesting argument i think it's
possibly true
but but even more so it's like what what
what are the dangers of alienating
people from the health system entirely
from the scientific establishment
entirely by politicizing it in this
manner we're not thinking that through
as far as i can tell and part of it's
just tremendous difficulty right i mean
all these things you talked about the
the secondary negative consequences of
the health measures it's also taken
everyone a while to see what those were
like kovid was an immediate threat it
was going to happen right now some of
these other things that you're talking
about like the increase in suicide rates
that that's sort of downstream right
it's and so no one was
that wasn't on the table when the when
the when the decisions were originally
being made
no and to be fair to policymakers we've
always got to be fair in these things no
one saw the nature of the second sort of
round of mutant variants and there would
be more of them and that's worrying in
itself so we don't quite know what we're
facing but i didn't want to pick up on
something that i think is critically
important two things that you said
firstly leadership here is that appeal
to reason
and to
a sense of responsibility to yourself
and your neighbor so i i buy that in
complete completely and and i would
argue again that it's been undermined by
this reliance on experts
no matter how highly you think of the
experts they're not the people we elect
to lead us if you see what i'm driving
at
they should advise leaders leaders
should leave and that's been a problem
across the west because of the breakdown
of trust in our leadership it it shot
through the roof when it looked as
though we could eliminate this thing in
australia governments were immensely
popular one very incompetent state
government was re-elected because it was
a there was a perception they'd kept
their people safe
and it didn't deserve to be re-elected
by any stretch of the imagination and i
you know i i think i'm a reasonable
judge of those things on all the broad
indicators they had not served their
state well
uh but
the other point that you raised that i
think so important i'm always struck by
hacksaw ridge the film that mel gibson
put together
and that's about conscientious objection
now
you stop and think about this for a
moment proportionality
and the darkest days of the second world
war when there were real doubts about
whether or not democracy and freedom
would survive
in the end and subject to some pretty
tough processes you could claim to be
and be recognized as a conscientious
objector that's what the film's about
you could say no i really my conscience
does not allow me to do this and you see
this is frank fruity's point i think uh
i don't want to verbally i'm only a
simple man but as i understand it our
first freedom is freedom of conscience
without that every other freedom i'm not
a believer in the hierarchy of freedoms
you know freedom of conscience freedom
of belief freedom of speech freedom of
assembly the right to meet with people
or not meet with people
and there's no hierarchy there they're a
package but in a sense the first is
freedom of conscience you know to think
through
what do i really believe
and then to be able to act out on that
conscience
that is the mark in the end of freedom
now it might be that during the second
world war society says well there will
be some downsides for you respect that
you don't have to go to the front line
and they may have to be here too i mean
i suspect that
airline customers here's an interesting
fact for you globally airline travel's
recovered to 70 of its pre-covered
levels australian air travel is down at
26 still quite interesting reflection on
our caution and our isolation in this in
this country
and yet we're one of the most
interconnected nations in the world in
terms of trade and in terms of tourism
inbound and outbound so it's an
interesting reflection on where we're at
in this country
but my point in all of this is that um
you have to
i i mean i think it's going to be hard
to be able to engage in all activities
if you've not been vaccinated unless we
can find a very quick way of testing and
i might be wrong on this but a friend of
mine was telling me that her son's in
germany and he went out for a coffee the
other day and the standard procedure is
that you get a little test on the way to
the coffee shop takes a few minutes and
if you're clear you're right so it's not
a question of vaccination it's whether
you've got covered
now that's an interesting way of looking
at it and if technology would allow for
that it might ease a lot of these things
i was run the other day by the minister
very thoughtful man from a church in in
my local area he said i'm not sure what
we're going to do if the state tells me
that i can't allow people to come and
worship in my church if they haven't had
a vaccination he said i'm deeply
troubled by that idea
and i i thought well i haven't thought
of that particular angle that's
troubling to me too
so what what do you think the best
rationale is for
mandatory vaccination it's like what is
the danger that what is actually the
danger
what's the best description of the
danger that's posed socially by people
who refuse to be vaccinated i mean
is the argument that they're also a
terrible danger to those who've been
vaccinated
i i
i mean as the vaccination rates increase
and and they're fairly high in canada i
think we're near 80 percent i i hope i'm
not wildly off the mark by that with
that uh estimate
i know it's much lower in australia or i
believe it is
um
i'm unclear about exactly the danger
that the unvaccinated are posing i mean
so what's your understanding given given
those vaccination rates what's what's
your understanding of that and what's
the justification for their restriction
of civil liberties
uh i have to say that's a very good
question jordan and i i'm as unclear as
you are i mean if
well we shouldn't be unclear about that
right you you'd hope that
you'd hope that in the positions that we
occupy we wouldn't be unclear about that
and it seems to me that if we're unclear
about that that plenty of other people
are unclear about it as well
and and that's that's obviously not a
good thing
so to illustrate the point that you're
raising if i've got this right now our
qantas the australian airline
has said that all of its staff must be
uh vaccinated and as i understand it uh
one of their very senior people has a
conscientious objection and has left the
organization i think i'm right in saying
that now his perspective presumably
would i mean it's a very important one
he would be asking a
question not only about civil liberties
but the practicalities which is what
you're posing as i understand it to
tease this out
if
if i'm about to get go through an
airport
through all the procedures involved
there and get on an airplane with people
who are
even if it's just one person like plane
who's not vaccinated if everybody else
has been vaccinated and they're safe
what's the problem
well it's precisely exactly what's the
problem and to what degree is that
sufficiently problematic so that civil
liberties should be importantly
curtailed
right because
and so i'm i'm unclear about exactly
what permission
being vaccinated
grants me
and i'm unclear about what
precise danger the unvaccinated posed to
the vaccinated if it's extremely high
then you think well then
what is the use of the vaccination and i
i don't want to overplay that obviously
because i believe the evidence suggests
that the vaccinated are much less likely
to
suffer severe consequences from covet
and much likely much less likely to
catch it
but but i'm still unclear about this are
the unvaccinated primarily posing a
danger to the other unvaccinated
and at some point
and then maybe people and maybe the
worry is well that's going to overwhelm
our health system it's going to
overwhelm our intensive care units
and so i guess a corollary to the policy
that i thought up earlier and i didn't
mention this was
we announce a date past which once the
vaccines are universally available we
announce a date past which things open
and we quadruple the money that we've
devoted towards icus
and because
it's not as if the lockdowns themselves
aren't expensive they're extraordinarily
expensive they're insanely expensive and
we haven't yet begun to pay for them
so
we set a limit we tell people
we inform people that the vaccinations
are available and then we prepare for
the fact that many people won't become
vaccinated but i still don't get the
exact danger and that could easily be my
my profound ignorance
but if it's the unvaccinated or
dangerous to the other and vaccinated
it's like well at some point
what are you gonna do about that force
people
that's not a good president
two thoughts come to mind uh one is that
um
one of the things that policymakers
would have to take into account i'd
imagine is the emergence of new variants
more contagious more dangerous
resistant to the vaccines and spreading
those very quickly
there may be dangers in there that have
to be thought through the other thing
about it is there's a world of
difference between saying
you must be vaccinated
per se and saying well if you choose not
to be that's okay but there may be some
situations where
where
you know you have to stay at bay so
hypothetically it might be to say
um uh you know
you don't have to be vaccinated but you
can't fly
that's i'm just plucking that out of the
air so you're absolutely free not to but
there are some things you can't do
if you're not vaccinated
in fact one of the things that we did in
this country so australia
one of the characteristics of the
country that i live in and love
is that we're amazingly
um
open to being regulated it's and a bit
weak on conscientious objection too
historically not as strong as america
and other western countries um
and
that regulation maybe it comes from the
benign way in which governments
regulated so much of our lives as i say
we've never had the turmoil of a you
know civil war and or of independence of
the agonies and intellectual exercises
that went into designing the american
declaration of independence we've not
we've not had those sorts of things
essentially we were a series of british
colonies put together
by an act of the british parliament in
1901 that federated us
and in the 1880s 1990s our best
thinkers often pretty flawed people and
pretty with selfish ambitions of being
statesmen and so forth in their own
little pond i suppose but they put
together a constitution that reflected
the very very best of the thinking and
the experiences and the learning
of particularly britain and america
but my point out of all of that is that
so government's been relatively benign
notwithstanding as i said earlier
australians have been prepared to fight
for freedom or to defend it they haven't
had to fight for it in the first place
and they've been very
we're amazingly accepting of regulation
in this country we were the first
country by in years by years to mandate
compulsory seatbelt wearing um
there's a whole plethora a whole raft of
things where australians have just been
quite happy to accept being told what to
do as smoking
advertising was banned here before
anywhere else i think that's right to
say um and so forth then you know to
take your point up government's
explained this is being done for public
health reasons and there was a wide
scale sort of acceptance of it so it
comes back to this if vaccinating is
important then it ought to be
positive arguments
uh for it and leadership that people
respect and they they say well i don't
feel threatened by this i accept the
arguments that for reasons a b and c it
makes sense and i should be responsible
whereas
coercion would ordinarily
create that resentment that suspicion
that distrust and the pushback that
you're talking about
so that's why the recognition of
conscientious objection i think is so
critical to the maintenance of freedom
in any genuinely free society that that
wants to
if you like persuade people of the value
of freedom
um well there's some food to persuade
people to become vaccinated for that
matter
no yeah i i don't know what these new
regulations in the uh the us are going
what kind of response they're going to
produce but i can't imagine that it's
going to do anything but exacerbate the
tension between the left and the right
that already exists in that country and
that
is
severe enough to be somewhat
destabilizing already
we're going to introduce vaccine
passports in
in my home province in ontario despite
the fact that there's a conservative
government in power at the moment and
there won't be as much of a reaction to
that in canada as there will be in the
u.s to similar measures but
is it it just seems to me that
that default to force is an admission
that the argumentation has been
stunningly inadequate and instead of
addressing the problem of the inadequate
argumentation
the shortcut is well those people are
too stupid to know what's good for them
and so it's and in this
and for the sake of everyone else's
well-being it's justifiable to force
them
that might even be okay if it was going
to produce the results that are intended
but i don't think it's going to i think
it's going to produce a kickback that
that will make things worse on the
vaccination front rather than better and
we we might ask ourselves too it's
like you know part of the reason the us
has given up on the war on drugs
is because
it was unenforceable
you had to push the state so far in it
police state direction
to
stop people from using substances like
marijuana
that everyone eventually just said look
man it's just the cure is worse than the
disease
and
well that's that's the danger that we're
facing i would say and it's always the
case with policy i understand that that
the cure can be worse than the disease
but
it reasonable people can certainly make
that argument
that there's there's tremendous danger
in
making an active invasive medical
procedure mandatory there's
terrible danger from a president
perspective
you know because what if it does turn
out for example that one of these
vaccines has unforeseen long-term
consequences and it's been given to
hundreds of millions of people
and i understand that
i understand medically that there is a
distinct possibility that that precise
thing will happen
and then yeah it's certainly not zero
the possibility and so yeah and and and
the fact that a percentage of the
population
perhaps exaggerates that
possibility because they're more
conspiratorial in their thinking or less
trusting or less more skeptical of
skeptical of government benevolence and
health and all of that i don't really
care
there's
you can't eradicate the possibility that
their objections
guided by their conscience let's say
are
and this is your point with regards to
conscientious objection objecting it's
like
you said that even when we were fighting
the nazis
we weren't so certain
that
you couldn't say no because you had a
different set of beliefs that were truly
invalidly held
so
and then i'm also concerned with the
about the president we're setting and i
suppose people who were opposed seat
belt laws and helmet laws and that sort
of thing had the same sort of notion
which is well
once you let the government decide
what's good for you
where does it stop
and
like i'm firmly convinced that maybe
this is my own paranoia i'm firmly
convinced that if the automobile had
been invented today
that the average person would would not
be allowed to drive
i don't think we would
i don't think we would allow that level
of risk and i think that's really
unfortunate so it's a good thing that
you know it came along slowly and sort
of snuck in
but because driving is a very dangerous
act and it's publicly dangerous too you
know you kill lots of people with your
we kill lots of people with their
automobiles
yet we're allowed to do it so to speak
and to think that we're even that the
right way of phrasing that is that we're
allowed is
that's not a good way of thinking about
it
so
it's inc yeah it's sort of if you like
get a helicopter view of all of this it
seems to be the things we're talking
about here go to the issues of
of the sort of
the the strength and the unity because
you can't separate the two
of the western democratic model at a
time
when the alternatives are really
starting to muscle up
globally
so this line that coverts accelerating
history strikes a chord with me
uh we're dividing more than ever
and i suspect to go back to what and i
don't want to misrepresent it i'm only
really referring to literally before we
came on what looks to be the news out of
america which i think is going to be
very contentious 80 million people being
told you will be vaccinated these sorts
of divisions this polarization this
tribalization this lack of confidence in
ourselves and our institutions
at a time when we're the world's looking
more like the 19th century with multiple
power centers many of them very hostile
to democracy to america in particular
uh that see places like canada and
australia as um sort of um
surrogate states of that sort of uh the
great satan america
uh
none of this fills me with a great deal
of confidence
that
we will be
will even recognize the freedoms that we
have now in the societies we live in in
another four or five generations another
four or five decades
uh i say that because of where we are
geographically i suppose in this region
here we're a long way where
australia's a very valuable bit of real
estate
uh
it's sparsely populated a large land
mass it's a long way from the other
democracies
with the exception of and the honourable
exception of indonesia
we're in an area where there is rising
authoritarianism led by one place in
particular
do we have collective willpower to pull
together
and say
we're going to have to make tough
decisions we've been very comfortable
for a long time
uh
and the first tough decision here is the
one that's now being openly spoken about
in australia they're actually saying it
and as i said i have confidence that
australians are being realistic about
this i actually think we will come
through this but it's so important we
have these debates
we now are saying we're going to have to
live with covert and accept that people
will die
awful thing to say but we're all going
to die and if we're not careful
we'll make this into such a mess
that
will die of more of us will die of more
causes in worse circumstances than right
under
right under a more authoritarian system
and it's worse to both worlds
uh you know i mean you've got enormous
economic challenges too i mean let's not
kid ourselves a reasonable degree of
prosperity is very important
to having a health system and nutrition
and educational employment opportunities
and travel
that give you lives worth living where
human beings can
flourish
right well and we've been able to in
some sense
devalue
i suppose devalue our currency by
distributing money
extraordinarily generously during this
time of crisis and fair enough in some
sense but
that isn't a sustainable response
and god only knows what damage we're
doing
to our future economic prosperity by
continuing to make it extraordinarily
difficult for many people to
engage in productive activity
how disheartening that is for people to
watch their
the businesses that they've poured their
heart and soul into take a terrible hit
and and and to have people adjust to
this new reality
uh that that may never allow them that
opportunity again
so
okay so practically speaking i mean
it's easy to sit and complain and say
you know doesn't this look grim and
shouldn't we be making smarter decisions
i
put forward for what it's worth you know
my thoughts on what a
reasonable policy might might
might look like one that balances
concern for health with the possibility
of continued freedom
what do you think might be done
concretely by political leaders in the
west to
to deal with the covid crisis more
more appropriately what what do you see
as a as a reasonable pathway forward
this say under strange uh reaction but
it's it's where i really genuinely come
from i think we need to lift people's
eyes to the real threats
to our future freedoms
and i think they're economic and
strategic
and i think out of that should be the
message that we really in western
countries within our countries and
actually amongst ourselves have more in
common
that is more durable and important and
imperative to preserve and work on if
you like
more interesting common than those which
divide us
and that requires a sort of leadership
that
that that we saw
you know
i keep thinking to myself we saw so much
of it out of america britain and america
frankly you know in the whole sort of
mess of the 1940s and then coming out of
it um there's this this
appealing to people
to
look to the broader interest to
recognize that hope lies in putting the
foundations down securing them for our
future which is our children and our
grandchildren in other words
break out of the fear we're cowering in
the corner in fear fear is a terrible
inhibitor you know more about this than
i do professionally
but we've become very afraid a lot of
what's happening at the moment's being
driven by fear
and it's fed on by send those who want
to sensationalize the issues and distort
the numbers and not talk about the costs
of a given line of action not talk about
the fact that there are issues here
other than the medical ones those sorts
of things um
and i think only then can we develop the
right sort of set of perspectives
but the subset of that one jordan is
that i don't think any of us yet have
worked out how to handle social media
with its capacity next thing i wanted to
ask you about actually because
i've been thinking about look i invited
uh
the leader of the opposition who's now
fighting an election in our country so
he's the leader of the progressive
conservative party and the liberals are
in power under justin trudeau and the
leader of the opposition is aaron
o'toole and i invited him to come on my
podcast
um
over the last couple of weeks and he
refused and you know he might have had
his reasons and i asked him at the last
minute but
these podcasts and i will i'd like to
hear your experience about them you know
they
there's no reason for politicians to be
using the media anymore as far as i can
tell
it can talk directly to people and and
maybe this opens up the possibility of
getting deeper insight into who our
potential political figures are
right because for so long
a politician had to think in terms of
delivering his message in a way that the
media would carry
but that's just not necessary now
because we can sit down like you and i
are sitting down
and
actually talk things through and and
then people can
be involved and engaged in that and
and
that seems to me to be
a hopeful
technology for the future and now you've
been
how long have you been running your
podcast and why did you do it and what
what do you think about that politically
i'm very
curious about that
uh well um
yeah look there's a bunch of issues in
there we
the problem with social media the
downside is it gives a megaphone to
people
to spread serious misinformation
conspiracy theories about astrazeneca or
whatever it happens to be that's the
downside and the danger the upside is
you can feel the terrible vacuum in
public information that's out there for
people who want to know what's really
going on and want to engage with ideas
and
as i've said probably ad nauseam i was
driven by that feeling that in my
country there are there is a hunger for
higher quality debate better content
more information
and it struck me and a couple of my
friends that
one of the ways to help counter that in
my country might be
what we embarked upon uh in fact i
launched with you thank you very much um
had several in the can ready to go with
but you were in australia at the time
and what you were saying so struck me as
topical and adventurous
um that um we launched with it and found
an extraordinary appetite for ideas and
for content
and the thing that encourages me
is that while look to be honest i often
despair of young people's lack of
understanding of their history of the
basics of their freedoms and democracy
they're so cynical about it they've been
fed the lines by their teachers who have
fed the lines out of universities often
that
participation in democracy is to be
cynical and to be an activist not a
participant and a contributor
and some of our best schools are letting
us down in this area in this country
some of our very very best schools as
well as
many of the mainstream ones now there
are many honorable exceptions i want to
add that
but
it just seemed to me that there is this
hunger and this appetite and as you said
to me
young people don't often read so much
now but they're still hungry for content
and changing technology they get it in
different ways there's an earlier
version of it that when we were in
government the prime minister of the
time john hard
recognized
bypass mainstream media where even in
those days the grabs were too short and
the bias was all too often you know
there were too many people in the media
seeking to campaign rather than four
but he recognized that talkback radio in
those days was a brilliant way to reach
a lot of people
and i think that's right he was able to
go over it he could talk directly he
could find hosts who would let him get
his message out even though some of them
might have interrupted a bit he could
still connect with people and that was
important how do you do that now the way
you and i are doing it
and i think that's invaluable and i
don't pretend in this conversation to
have had all the answers but at least i
think we've teased out the issues
and recognize
there's a lot of food for thought in all
of this and fundamental to it is to
recognize at the end of it our freedoms
matter governments should be functions
of our will
we should not be the puppets of
government
in the democracies that's incredibly
important we've got to establish
that we should respect them whilst they
are there but they are our servants at
the moment we don't respect them
strangely enough and yet we expect them
to solve every problem and the system
breaks down people become cynical so
what have i found well i found
i i am constantly amazed at how often
people will pull me up in the streets
and say i heard your conversation with
that person or this person or whatever
and because i try not to feed my own
opinions in too much most people know
what i think
but most of the time i'm trying to
provide a conduit for people to listen
and to hear what others have got to say
when partly because of bias and
positioning
a lot of views are hard to get out and
partly because it's such an instant
world the 30-second grab doesn't work if
you want to
draw the great lessons out of the gulag
archipelagos you and i did in our first
conversation you can't do that in a
30-second grab it's impossible we're
dumbing people down
unwittingly
because technology has in the mainstream
media sort of led to that outcome
we're breaking the finances of
mainstream media of course
by doing what what you and i do
and so that means that the journalistic
qualities go down more and more because
they don't have the resources to pay
people to do really high quality
investigative stuff and what have you
anyway i'm being long-winded but
i i've
i have learned a huge amount
it's something worth
considering and contemplating in detail
because
this is
a stunningly revolutionary new
technology i mean youtube was just kind
of a novelty item when it first popped
up
but the fact that everyone is now a
video producer and a video and a
sophisticated video consumer
it changes the world in ways that that
have only
barely begun to manifest themselves and
we certainly don't understand it because
the technology runs way faster than our
understanding of its of its consequences
but it seems to me that it should become
increasingly incumbent on people who
have political ambitions
to engage
directly with the public
in this manner that that should become a
standard expectation of
political figures and of
of the general population
because
if you can't
handle yourself in a 90-minute
conversation if you're if your ideas
aren't well enough developed or if you
don't have the character or you reveal
your hand in some manner well that
that's something that should happen
and
the fact that everything has to be
condensed down in some sense to sound
bites
means that people who are good at doing
that or who have a good team to do that
they get the spoils
but it's no way to run a serious
operation and
this technology is
is available to anyone who
who cares to use it now
so
what what have you seen
what do you understand the understanding
of political figures in
australia with regards to social media
like do they understand
the significance of its existence the
potential that it has
some do
some do some set up massive cynical
exercises to try and control social
media to participate and you know
and set up movements you know come with
me sort of stuff
where it's all spin and it plays on the
sort of hashtag type stuff
but then
at the other extreme
i have been
delighted and amazed at the number of
um
people right up the political scale who
who listen to the conversations that
i've held and
to go to the parliament house and have a
senior person from the other side of
politics to the one that i was involved
with and it's happened several times
come up and say gee i enjoyed your
podcast
that is gold to me
and then to know that there are several
cabinet ministers who often tap in
particularly if i talk about defence or
if i talk about
the sorts of things that you and i talk
about
and then one of the things that i have
noticed though this is an interesting
one and i've not got to the bottom of it
i don't quite understand it
um is that uh
my countrymen are more
interested in listening to somebody from
america or britain than from anywhere
else including their own country
so a couple of the most important
conversations that i've done or quite a
few quite a few on defense uh with our
former prime minister who is now the
father of the nation in many ways and
was widely seen that way
uh and yet there's relatively
thin interest
um
talking to i mean the ones the talks the
conversations that you and i have had
this is actually the fourth and it's
very kind of you to have me as a guest
um
they they have flown off the racks so to
speak and generated huge interest and
the here's the one i know i've said this
many times so you know forgive me
listeners who have heard me say this but
nothing drives me on more than when i
meet young men and women
however who are seeing through the
paucity and the superficiality of what
they've been fed
as young australians and have really
clicked
to you know a deep philosophical uh and
meaningful understanding your point
indeed uh that the sort of things can
only be learned through long-form
discussions
about
why our country's different you know
when i was in parliament one of the few
you know i'm reasonably economically dry
one of the few subsidy arrangements that
i agreed with was that we subsidised
kids
schools from around australia so yeah it
was cheap for them no matter how far
this is a very big country to come to
canberra and see democracy in action
and i always used to look forward to
meeting with them was always fascinating
so we'd have a discussion about the
parliament house and its endless
corridors and the chambers and the prime
minister and all of these sorts of
things
and then i'd spring it on to them and
say now how many of you were told before
you came down here by your mums and dads
and maybe even your teachers are you
going to canberra are you that place you
know it's all hot here and the
politicians are useless and the
government's no good
and every hand would go up
that's australia you know
we're we were once helpfully skeptical
and downright cynical i think about our
political processes and the people in
them but if you then said them okay so
if if the government's making a mess of
it you name me a country that you'd like
to live in in preference to australia
and occasionally somebody would say
america or they'd say canada they might
say new zealand they'd say they're all
democracies
and then we talk about the differences
and because it it never hit them
and once you start to unpack that stuff
and the sort of conversations that
that you and i so enjoy because i enjoy
them enormously
there's a lot of people that tap into it
and say gee that's interesting that's
really got me thinking
and and was it margaret mead who said
you know society's
uh you know i've often been changed by
just a small group of people getting
together and thinking things through
indeed that's the only way societies
have ever changed and so
what drives me on is the hope that
whether they agree with me or disagree
with me even if they come out in a
different place if these conversations
that we have
help raise up
tomorrow's leaders well boy we're going
to need them and they'll have to be
people of vision and encourage and
courage and of insight
and nothing struck me more than that
first conversation where you had and you
were quite emotional about it you said
that you'd been in melbourne and
you'd had some young men there who had
responded positively what you'd said you
just said they
just need a little bit of encouragement
because they're not getting it and
they're not
i've never forgotten that man and i
resolve at that point because you're so
open
and you make yourself vulnerable and
that must be very costly at times that i
would seek to do the same
so i've done that several times
consciously as a result of that first
conversation i've opened up more about
me and the hope of that's useful for
young people and if others want to
criticize me if older people say oh we
wouldn't have said that in our day dear
or whatever so it doesn't matter if
there's one person out there
and i know there's more than that
because i've met them who have been
impacted and have thought things through
put down some foundations that they
otherwise wouldn't have well it's all
been worth it
that's a great place to close
so thanks very much for agreeing to meet
with me again i really appreciate it and
to to wander through this minefield and
you know uh
it's it's
it's not something that anyone knows how
to do properly
but
you know we can all hope and strive to
do it right and hope that we don't do
what should do too much damage while
we're trying to figure it out so
i i'm hoping to come to australia next
year again to perhaps to tour again if i
can manage it so
if i do come down there i'd sure be more
than pleased to see you again and to
meet and so i'd like that very much so
thank you very much again for coming in
did and thank you very much it's an
honor and
it's it's terrific to see you
firing on all eight again
[Music]
you